the indictment of Donald Trump is
historic unprecedented and just the tip
of illegal Iceberg the New York charges
reportedly 30 of them are expected to be
detailed on Tuesday focused on a hundred
and thirty thousand dollar hush money
payment to a porn star during the 2016
presidential campaign we do know it
centers around uh you know a legal very
common confidentiality agreement that
was signed years and years ago with uh
Stormy Daniels and between her attorneys
and and Michael Cohen but the New York
case is likely not the most dangerous
for the former president compared to the
other investigations which include
efforts to overthrow or overturn the
2020 election the New York case seems to
be the least serious of them all in
Georgia a grand jury has recommended
indictments for multiple people over
interference in Georgia's 2020 election
it's not clear Trump is among them but
legal experts say this conversation
between Trump and Georgia Secretary of
State amounts to a Smoking Gun I just
want to find
uh 11 780
votes we is one more that we have the
jury 4 woman offered this murky but
tantalizing tidbit there are certainly
names
another legal threat special counsel
Jack Smith's probe of Trump's handling
of classified documents Last Summer the
FBI seized more than a hundred of them
from Trump's Florida home after he
refused requests to turn them over Smith
is also investigating Trump's actions
during the January 6 2021 attack on the
U.S Capitol
Trump has dismissed all the
investigations as partisan witch hunts
but until the New York indictment The
Man known as Teflon Don has faced real
repercussions only at The Ballot Box
a Northwestern University psychologist
says Trump's risk-taking even a moral
qualities are key to his popularity
here's this Beast out there doing it for
me going out there fighting for me
saying what I feel deep down and that's
attractive I mean like you know he may
be he may be a narcissist he may be a
sociopath but he's my narcissist and my
sociopath whether that approach Works in
court might well be tested again and
again John hendron Al Jazeera New York